có khoảng lý đi điều và phòng chống thiên tai bốn nguyện và môi trường.
Mới lũ tường ngày 8,5 bẩy đến người dơ sáng ngày 1,2 tháng 5
đã làm bang người thiệt mạng tại sản giá phù tình xa la.
Mới lần cũng gây sặt lợt tài lý dương,
bới khối luận gần một gì mấy khối đất đã.
Tại kí lưng mấy thái chiến cậm một trong năm gây trên tình lộ một lấy bà
đoạn qua bản, ngờ cài, sản yên sân, làm ác thách st không?
Chúng khi đá có thể tình lâu cây, mưa cầm giông lốc làm một người bị thương.
Mới bán nhà ở bị ảnh hưởng giữa sắp lợt ngập ủng,
tả ninh tà lỗi mình gặp.
Chính quyền địa phương đã sơ tảnh 8,5 dân đến người ăn toàn.
Ngay sau khi tình tài xảy ra, các địa phương đã không có đặc lực lượng số hịn trường.
Hỗ trợ người dân khóc phục hộ quả,
dạ sóa thông kê thi thái và sớm một địa đời sống sản xuất.
Cô quả lý đi điều và phòng chống thiên tai suy chi trực bán 2 tư trên ai tư.
Theo giỏi trạm trẻ dịch biến thử tiết,
chuyển các thông tin sự báo cảnh báo đến cái địa phương.
Đồng thời pho yên mưa bây giờ lo viện nằm người đi nhảnh thương sẵn kỹ năng phòng chống thiên tai.
Tớ khoảng sống trịu thề báo tại các khu vực cóm vi cơ chuanh hưởng,
huồn mơ lớn, lũ ngập lục lụ quách, xà lợt đất, lấp sét và mưa đả.
Cái địa phương tiếp tục tổ chức trực bán chủ đồng trình khai các bạn pháp ứng phó,
và phó phục phộ quả thiên tai.